bonsoir c'est normal pour une petite
vidéo calme je voulais juste vous parler
d'un petit délire c'est ses potes tu vas
ses amis qu'on aime bien mais qui
parfois sont un peu agaçant tu vas voir
un peu énervant on n'a pas envie tarbes
et des petites barques sur la tête des
fois alors déjà on a tous ces fameux
potes qui sont en couple
tu voi x ou simple prétexte qu'ils sont
en couple ben il faut plus aucune sortie
c'est à dire que pour eux l'amusement
entre amis ça n'existe plus avec les
autres on va en boîte
vous venez avec nous ben nous on va
rentrer parce que céline elle est
fatiguée
allez vous venez avec nous non mais
c'est gentil on a déjà fait une grosse
soirée la semaine dernière on a du mal à
s'en remettre
ah ouais vous avez fait quoi ben on
allait au cinéma on a vu un film en 3d
après on a tous cette potes des fois tu
sais pas si c'est ta pote
ou si c'est ta prof de français et donc
hier j'étais avec la soeur annie qu on
dit pas la soeur annie qu on dit la
soeur de nico ouais enfin bon bref en
tout cas on peut manger des haricots et
abandonner mes parents ont dit pas les
haricots ont dit les haricots
merci ok attend juste une question
l'expression c'est ferme ta gueule ou
ferme ta grosse gueule bat normalement
expression de base c'est ferme ta gueule
n'a pas de live spécial ferme ta gueule
j'aime bien ça c'est lui c'est efficace
et ouais donc j'étais en train de manger
des haricots et c'est des fois t'es
content parce que tu as un nouveau
vêtement qui correspond un peu à ton
style tu un peu le seul à le revoir
il ya toujours un pote qui comprend pas
ça un qui qui va au magasin et qu'ils
achètent le même vraiment le même
identique
c'est un crime un mec a pris le même
temps que moi c'est bon ça va c'est pas
grave mais tu n'as pas ton propre style
là t'as pas envie d'acheter des
vêtements mais c'est juste que je suis
là il mal et bien c'est tout les 10000
manteau sur terre la boue mêmes manteaux
mois d'octobre ben c'est le hasard il ya
ce pote avec qui tu pourras jamais avoir
une discussion discrète la discrétion
c'est pas une de ces compétences sont
discrètement est derrière toi et mes
filles elle est trop belle magnifique
manu tu fais discret
pas mal quand je rencontre une fille qui
te plaît avec qui tu as un peu envie de
sortir
mais que sait pas encore tout à fait tu
vois je pense qu'il faut pas tout de
suite la présenter à tes potes parce que
y en a toujours un qui comprend pas
c'est qui comprend pas cette démarche
nouvelles connaissances à chanter se
laissera salut si tu vas d'où sa 18e
étape
mais j'habite aussi notre soutien ça
n'en valait tyerman prier aussi ce pote
tactile 8 qui peut pas s'empêcher de te
parler sans te toucher sans te palper le
corps save anormal que tu as fait ce
week end
j'étais bien sauf que je me disais le
jour où ce mec va rencontrer un autre
mec tactile ça va être un petit peu
chelou
ben alors ça la famille mes frères et
soeurs tout ça c'est bon mais à
il a certes un pote n'a pas besoin de
leur dire de se mettre à l'aise quand tu
les invite chez toi naturellement ils
sont déjà un peu comme chez eux
lucas excuse moi je sais j'étais même
pas 10 mais évidemment mets toi à l'aise
après comme chez toi
évidemment on parle juste du salon parce
que j'aime pas trop le blanc un peu
hôpital france est pêché dans le bar et
je sais tout ça quand tu rentres dans le
salon c'est la base
le minimum
en tout cas qu'ils soient agaçant ou pas
les poteaux les amis heureusement qu'ils
sont là parce que quand tu es en galère
quand t'as plus rien et tu as besoin de
quelqu'un c'est sur eux que tu peux
compter alloway mais que tu appelles
parce que demain je déménage et j'aurais
voulu savoir si tu pouvais venir m'aider
à temps sur youtube sur l'époque à son
nom enfin si si mais halo halo love